US News and World Report is out this
morning with its ranking of the best
states in the country
Iowa comes out on top of this year's
list followed by Minnesota and Utah the
report ranked Mississippi 49th and
Louisiana last it measured States in
eight different categories Iowa ranked
first overall in infrastructure and in
the top 10 on health care opportunity
education and quality of life Iowa's
Republican governor Kim Reynolds joined
fellow governors yesterday at the White
House this morning she's with us at the
table along with US News and World
Report editor and chief content officer
Brian Kelly good morning to both of you
good morning governor before we get to
the rankings you said about you said
quote the federal government has to play
a role in deciding firearm restrictions
what kind of role should the federal
government play well you know yesterday
we had the opportunity to meet with the
president through the National Governors
Association so governors of both parties
have the opportunity to sit down and
listen to some of the president's ideas
I think it's just really important that
we look at this from a holistic
perspective we all have a role to play
in this I'm a mother I'm a grandmother
of nine my daughter is a teacher so
we've had some pretty heart-to-heart
conversations about what they're doing
in their school we need to strengthen
the laws that are on the books we need
to do a better job with background
checks we need to make sure that we're
doing everything we can to keep firearms
out of the hands of people that
shouldn't have them whether they have
mental illness or domestic abuse and
with the daughters a teacher do you
think it's a good idea to arm teachers
well you know I again I think we need to
look at everything I think that needs to
be very thoughtful I think it needs to
be a local decision I don't think that
that's something that should be mandated
from the federal level I think they have
a role to play that you want your
daughter armed well if they're trained
and if they have the proper vetting and
they're you know are capable of doing
that that's a decision that Jessica
needs to make you know so I think that
it's important there are states that are
doing that there are states that have
said governor's that said I've talked to
our educators and our administrators
they're not interested in doing that so
but we can't I think it's so important
that we just not focus on single
issues we just can't we need to look for
ways to secure our schools single point
of entrance we need to make sure that we
have mental health counselors in our
schools we need to make sure that you
know we have possibly a law enforcement
security guard in each one of the
schools we need to look at mental health
we've got a significant comprehensive
mental health bill that we've been
working on in the state of Iowa that
should hopefully go to the floor of that
of the house this week to make sure that
we have access and that we're
identifying needs sooner rather than
later so there's a whole host of things
that I think we need to be looking at
well governor it's great to meet you we
love the state of Iowa I love the state
of Iowa I love the state of Iowa course
you do and Bryan it's so interesting to
hear so when sewers ranked the states
and last year Iowa's was 6th and now
it's 1st what's Iowa doing right on the
job nine months pretty impressive
yeah well there has been some good
continuity there sir yeah and the
administration's governor Reynolds was
the lieutenant governor before but they
are just good as john said in the
graphic they're just good at a lot of
things we look at 75 different factors I
mean we're looking at whether people go
to their doctor's appointment and how
much that how much it costs and
graduation rate from high school and
higher ed cost there's so many factors
in there and when you when you add up
the numbers they're number one they beat
Massachusetts that we were here with us
last year so there definitely is a
competition I think among the state's
seven of the top ten states have
Republican governors right mm-hmm
does that say anything about how they're
leading those states you know it's a
nonpartisan survey we're not kicking
we're not picking sides on this it is
just about the numbers
there is probably some lessons to be
learned there some of the states also
are contiguous you have Iowa Minnesota
and Nebraska now which probably tells
you something about I don't know Nordic
or the Jean long gray for the Midwest
there's a whole there's some interesting
patterns but you know this is the second
year we've done it so i beginning to
find a lot of interesting things i I
agree with Nora with her I've been to
Iowa a couple of times and had a great
experience every time I've been but I
was also 90 percent white so how are
people like me supposed to feel about it
getting the number one slot you know I'm
cinnamon brown with a dollop of caramel
so a person of color
so what do you say to people of color
who are looking at this about 15% right
of one tree yes 50 yes yes yes blacks
yeah well I was a pretty diverse state
in a number of regards I mean I think
it's the governor can speak to this it's
not a farm state you know manufacturing
is the primary you know the economy it's
it's a very interesting developing
evolving state there's there's a large
Hispanic population there and so I think
you know well I think we are a very
diverse state and very welcoming state
first of all I just want to say thank
you
first of all its what an honor to
recognize Iowans that are making a
difference in communities every single
day all across our state and Iowa truly
is a place where if you work hard dream
big anything is possible
and I'm honestly a product of that I
grew up in a small town in Iowa town of
about 500 people Kevin and I when we
were raising our three daughters I to
make ends meet I checked at height at a
grocery store during the weekends and on
nights and even with all of that I'm
sitting here today as the governor of
the state of Iowa and I think it's
reflective of the opportunities that
exist within our state yeah Kevin is her
husband who's in oh yeah yeah yes my
husband yeah so but not everything is
rosy in life so what is the biggest
challenge for you as a governor right
now that you're trying to tackle well
and I think this is consistent across
the state we have an economy that grows
that's growing we have a great business
environment and as I talk to job
creators there they're looking for
people with skills and so I'm working
with Iowans every single day first of
all kids in high school to make sure
that they know there's many
opportunities different career pathways
to great opportunities in the state of
Iowa but working with adult learners to
to help give them skills so that they
can have a great job and have a great
quality of life and so that is the
number one focus I think if you you know
if we have a talent pipeline ready to
meet the needs and we're providing
opportunities for Iowans in our state to
really have a great quality of life
that's how we're going to continue to
succeed and stay on top and we're number
one graduation rate in the country I
have been very involved as lieutenant
governor in stem
science technology engineering and math
with a focus on underrepresented and
underserved to make sure sooner rather
than later that these kids know that
they can do or be anything that they
want to be it helps build confidence and
it helps match them up with new with
great opportunities in Iowa well big
congratulations to you thank you thank
you governor Kim Reynolds Brian Kelley
always good to have you here thank you
thank you